der hollywood star keanu reeves ist ja
gerade in der hauptstadt für
dreharbeiten und jetzt sind neue bilder
aufgetaucht sonja kirsche chefin ist bei
nina erzählt uns was ist los was ist auf
den bildern zu sehen er sich dass das
schon richtig gesagt piano ries ist seit
einigen monaten in berlin und dreht die
fortsetzung von der matrix trilogie also
matrix 4
und vielleicht kannst du dich noch daran
erinnern wir haben letzte woche war es
bilder gezeigt wie kerner rief seine
freundin alexandra grant verabschiedet
ihr ganz süß ein busserl gibt und dann
mit einer tüte und einer einer einer
tasche um den um den um die schulter
quasi davon schreite zu seinem hotel wo
er sich aufhält während er dreht und
jetzt gibt es neue bilder also gut eine
woche später haben wir fast die gleiche
szenerie selbe tasche serie tüte selbe
jacke selber hose selben schuhe selbe
freundin immerhin weil das wäre eine
andere geschichte
aber ein ganz entscheidendes detail ist
anders und zwar hat kern rief sich von
seiner langen wunderschönen mähne
verabschiedet und trägt jetzt eine kerze
weiß man denn warum er das gemacht hat
ja ich sagte ja entscheidendes detail
und zwar möchte ich dazu sagen dass
alles um das drehbuch von matrix42
wahnsinnig geheimnis eigentlich weiß
keiner was der inhalt wird alle matrix
fans sind super gespannt und und wollen
natürlich wissen was in dieser
fortsetzung passiert denn eigentlich
sind ja nee und trinity also die
hauptdarsteller gestorben in dem dritten
teil
und immerhin ist ja jetzt klar es wird
wieder mitspielen und diese klasse
deutet auf einzelnen alle matrix fans
wissen es 1999 in dem ersten film gibt
es eine szene in der er in einem
brutkasten mit glatze auftaucht
verkabelt und in schleim und wir wissen
dass gerade in einem 7,5 tonner
ganz ganz viel schreiben an fett
transportiert wurde
zudem wissen wir dass loris am z
gesichtet wurde mit schläuchen am nacken
und dieses foto ist natürlich
wahrscheinlich der beweis dafür dass es
so eine szene in diesem buch kasten
verkabelt noch einmal geben wird also 21
jahre später
wie genau das dann in dem film sein wird
das wissen wir natürlich noch nicht aber
das ist natürlich ein wahnsinnig tolles
detail und eine eine tolle info für alle
matrix fans ja damit hast auch nicht zu
viel gespart hat man da nicht was soll
da wir machen keine spoiler
aber was man auch sagen kann reese wird
uns in der hauptstadt noch ein bisschen
länger beglücken
denn durch corona die matrix crew hatte
einige corona fälle gerade erst wieder
zwei da war ein schauspieler und eine
maske nach in unseren informationen
infiziert krone hat natürlich sehr viel
durcheinander gewirbelt und laut unseren
informationen wird kia no noch bis ende
2021 in der stadt bleiben zumindest die
matrix dreharbeiten werden solange
momentan das ist der stand der dinge
laut unseren informationen stattfinden
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dir hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren